do you know who Magnus Carlson is yes
who is Magnus
player I think he's a champion yeah yeah
a world champion Joe Magnus Carlson is
uh yes I met Tim you met Matt I met him
I also met there and who's the greatest
chess player of all time
Carlson right you know who Magnus
Carlson is of course you know that she's
met Magnus Carl I met him I did yeah
nice he was the world chess champion and
I am wearing his shoes are you Magnus
Carls I am Magnus Carlson I'm not Magnus
I mean I wish you were I know I wish I
was too hey sir do you like my shoes I
think they're awesome first of all how
sexy are these shoes
yeah one to ten I'll say eight eight
point six okay yeah I like this goldish
color that's what I said who can you
guess by looking at him whose shoes they
are some chess guy some chess guy when
you look at these shoes these are Magnus
Carlson shoes ah okay so therefore they
are the best therefore they are the best
that's right who's the greatest chess
player of all time it's Magnus Carlson
right what if I told you I took these
shoes right off his feet oh yeah
is it real
take a look get close these are Magnus
Carlson limited edition
Clyde suede shoes from Puma would you
take shoes off of Magnus Carlson's feet
if you could get away with it
yeah no no okay come on thank you for
your time also Norway we love you
[Music]